we've heard some rumors about you
Netflix apparently your team goes to
drastic lengths to protect the TV series
they're working on and to do this they
come up with some really interesting
rules for the cast to follow problem is
the cast of stranger things had a little
bit of a hard time following every
single one of your rules while we
totally understand wanting to protect
your plot lines can you leave Joe
Curie's hair out of your contract yeah
we didn't think so
think that's weird keep watching to find
out which cast member actually had to
gain weight for his role what you say
during interviews the cast of stranger
things is downright hilarious which is
why every talk show wants them to make a
special appearance problem is some of
the cast members are scared of saying
too much during interviews francesco
reali who plays Heather Holloway told
cinema blend that she was very scared of
Netflix and they're very binding
contracts the internet TV network
expects it two actors to be tight-lipped
about certain topics which is why they
send out a massive sheet to their actors
telling them which topics they can and
can't talk about don't mess with the
hare Harrington when you're a part of an
ongoing TV series like stranger things
you need to play by the duffer Brothers
rules and one of their rules has a lot
to do with their characters hairdos
Steve Harrington isn't nicknamed the
hare for nothing which is why chopping
off his locks just isn't an option
oh yeah yes I'll do fine that is unless
the duffer brothers are willing to try
something new don't wear your own makeup
if there's one rule every actor has to
follow it's coming to set with a fresh
face on that means leaving your own
makeup and products at home despite
knowing about the strict rule Millie
Bobby Brown showed up to the set of
stranger things covered head-to-toe in
glitter it took the makeup squad about
45 minutes to get the glitter off of her
which delayed the shooting schedule but
according to Miller she has no idea
where the glitter came from lose the ABS
Billy for those of you who don't know de
coeur Montgomery played the role of
Jason in 2017 to Power Rangers so he
literally got shredded for the part but
when it came to playing Billy the
duffer brothers weren't fond of Baker's
six-pack abs after all guys in the 80s
weren't super shredded to look the part
Baker changed up his diet and put on a
few extra pounds get in shape Steve when
Joe Curie first landed the role of Steve
Harrington the duffer brothers told him
that Steve was a professional swimmer so
Joe trained for a total of six weeks to
get a swimmer's body he was expecting to
wear a speedo throughout the series so
he put in some extra work but when Joe
showed up to the set six weeks later the
duffer brothers told him that his
character swimming background had been
cut from the script watch what you post
on social media although this one may
seem obvious there are still a lot of
actors who need to be reminded to watch
what they post on social media as a
matter of fact some producers are so
nervous about leaks that they forbid
their actors to pull the phone's out at
all posting a picture of the set on
snapchat or Instagram can get an actor
sued or fired in the blink of an eye no
schedule conflicts allowed booking as
many gigs as possible might seem like
the way to go when you're an actor but
it can actually get you in trouble very
quickly actors have to make sure that
their kids won't cause schedule
conflicts of any kind
when fin wolfhard was cast as Mike he
was already set to play Ritchie in it
luckily delays caused the production for
it to get pushed back an entire year so
fin was allowed to take on both stranger
things and it at the same time don't
talk bad about your fellow actors this
one may seem pretty obvious but every
now and then actors need to be reminded
to never bad-mouthed any of their fellow
actors producers or directors during
interviews not only is this poor
etiquette but it gives the public a bad
impression and causes feuds between
co-stars if you don't have anything nice
to say don't say anything at all choose
a difficult password during the same
interview with cinema blend
Franchesca reali also revealed that
Netflix takes a lot of preventative
measures to protect their scripts and
set leaks
Francesca mentioned that any advance
screeners sent out to cast members were
password-protected according to the
actress Netflix goes the extra mile to
keep their ongoing productions
top-secret but we wouldn't expect
anything less after all who wants to
have their favorite show spoiled before
it hits the small screen don't punch
your fellow actors now this strict rule
might seem obvious to some of you
because well physical altercations are
never okay no matter where they happen
but oddly enough Charlie Heaton had to
be reminded of this Golden Rule Charlie
and Joe who portrayed Jonathan and Steve
respectively actually got physical
during their first fight scene and well
poor Joe ended up getting punched in the
face for real
twice although it was a total accident
on Charlie's part producers felt they
needed to remind him to take it easy on
poor Joe so there you have it guys 10
strict rules the cast of stranger things
has to follow which one do you find most
surprising tell us in the comments below
thanks for watching the things don't
forget to Like and subscribe so you
never miss another video we'll catch you
next time
[Music]